[Music]
so last night we played you long clips
from the president's recent address at
Mount Rushmore and may have been the
best speech Donald Trump has ever given
it was succinct and clear and it was
true and for all of those reasons the
Democratic Party and as many minions
absolutely hated it they denounced the
speech and this may not come as a
complete surprise to you
that's quote racist now that's a slur
long divorce from any actual meaning but
we should tell you that as a factual
matter it's a lie
there was nothing even conceivably
racist about Trump's speech go watch it
for yourself there's not a racist word
or idea in the whole thing the only time
Trump even brought up the civil war was
to praise Abraham Lincoln who thank God
won it he never mentioned the
Confederacy or anyone in the Confederacy
in said Trump praised unabashed American
heroes like George Washington Clara
Barton the Wright brothers Jackie
Robinson senator Tammy Duckworth of
Illinois watched Trump's speech or
claims she did her summary of it
quote he spent all his time talking
about dead traitors George Washington
Clara Barton Jackie Robinson they are
all according to Tammy Duckworth dead
traitors pretty shocking in case you
think we're being unfair here in the
same interview senator Duckworth was
asked if we should tear down statues to
George Washington sure she responded
let's talk about it we played that tape
for you last night and we noted how
grotesque it was only someone who hates
the country would suggest ripping down
monuments to its founder apparently
Tammy Duckworth saw what we said she
didn't disagree with it exactly instead
she questioned our right to criticize
her at all since she was once injured
while serving in the Illinois Army
National Guard that's what passes for an
argument in modern identity politics
they don't address the points that you
make they question your right to make
them at all
the irony of course is that George
Washington himself the dead traitor
Tammy Duckworth has such contempt for
also served in the military Washington
spent most of his adult life under arms
he fought in two wars at one point
during the winter of 1777 Washington
lost almost a quarter of his entire army
to cold and malnutrition so George
Washington paid his dues
he was as we might say today a combat
veteran and by the way Washington also
created the country we live in George
Washington was a genuinely great man but
two morons like Tammy Duckworth
Washington is just some old white guy
who needs to be erased let's tear down
his statues rename our capital city
Sharpton or Mandela and let the
revolution continue but hold on not so
fast
changes that profound deserve it debate
not some fake national conversation
where they scream commands at you and
you get to obey but a vigorous reasoned
exchange between adults we wanted to
have an exchange like that with Tammy
Duckworth tonight so we called her
office and we invited her on the show
her flack informed us that before even
considering our request we must first
issue a public apology for criticizing
Tammy Duckworth in other words I will
not debate you until first you admit
you're completely wrong
keep in mind Tammy Duckworth is not a
child
at least not technically she's a sitting
United States Senator who was often
described as a hero yet Duckworth is too
afraid to defend her own statements on a
cable TV show what a coward Tammy
Duckworth is also a fraud five years ago
while she was a member of Congress
whistleblowers from a VA hospital in
Illinois approached Duckworth to report
the widespread mistreatment of sick
veterans remember that story the
whistleblowers met with Tammy Duckworth
three times she refused to help them
according to a cardiologist who attended
those meetings
Duckworth dismissed the systemic cruelty
inflicted on dying veterans by saying
that quote that's just how it is at the
VA the whistleblowers were horrified by
her response ultimately in frustration
they took their story to the media and
it became a national scandal this is the
person lecturing the rest of us about
her moral authority as a veteran spare
us Tammy Duckworth is a callous hack who
ignored the suffering of actual veterans
when it actually mattered she has no
moral authority she is just a politician
like the rest of them she works for us
this is a democracy
she has an obligation to explain herself
and answer our questions and our first
question would be how can you lead a
country you despise and that's not
something we would ask only to
tammy duckworth by the way hating
America is a major theme in the
Democratic Party right now it's
everywhere turn on the TV
here's congresswoman Ilhan Oh Marge just
today and if anyone should love America
it's johann Omar this country rescued
her from a squalid Kenyan refugee camp
and made her a national figure quite an
ascent but he'll haunt Omar is not
grateful she hates us for it watch omar
tell us it is time to dismantle our
country as long as our economy and
political systems prioritize profit
without considering who is profiting who
is being shut out we will perpetuate
this inequality so we could not stop at
criminal justice system we must begin
the work of dismantling the whole system
of oppression wherever we find it
dismantle the American economy and the
American system of government
institutions that generations of
Americans built over hundreds of years
tear them down to Ilhan omar and tammy
duckworth and so many others on the Left
we don't like them we hate this country
we want a new country the problem is
there are many of us here who do like
this country we live here we don't want
to destroy it we have every right to
fight to preserve our nation and our
heritage and our culture and when
vandals like Tammy Duckworth and johann
Omar tell us that we're not allowed to
question their patriotism even as they
scream about how horrible America is we
have every right to laugh in their faces
and we should